thank you
thank you
getting one of these now rare wristbands
is pure luck they've only just managed
to get them but there's no guarantee
they'll make it to westminster hall in
time there's now a constant chase to
find the end of the line
this is what they wanted to join the
pilgrimage hundreds of thousands have
devotedly made
veteran tom is struggling with his hip
after walking through the night but is
only too obliging to go the extra mile
at some stage i was beginning to wonder
a little bit whether someone will come
along
with the close sign and say sorry or too
late and to actually see the building
for the first time
that's quite amazing as well
how does it make you feel seeing the
building
very emotional actually
some generations need no reminding of
the queen's seven decades of service but
others are still learning about it
tell me why jude did you want to be part
of this today um i wanted to come see
the queen because
i mean me and my mom always
watched the documentaries together we
really just want to prepare us back
barely any sleep wasn't going to stop
adele from doing the same
all week i felt i needed to be here so
i made the trip this morning i had about
three hours sleep basically
it really is quite incredible that this
cube five miles long hasn't stopped
moving since wednesday evening hundreds
of thousands of people putting one foot
in front of another day and night
all with one intention and all for one
woman
those that are among the last to wander
through the hall like former paratrooper
steve feel lucky
i'm very relieved
i i had to do it i've planned it over
the last three or four days i'd come
down in a small motor home i've planned
everything i'm staying up now for 48
hours and i'm going to the funeral
tomorrow for which another queue has
already begun this time to see a state
funeral britain hasn't seen for 57 years
so they too can say they were here
and witnessed an extraordinary moment in
history
ash naharinag sky news in central london